hi herzlich willkommen bei ZDF F live
schön dass ihr dabei seid wir sprechen
hier heute über Cyprus confidential das
ist eine von ZDF vom Spiegel und vom
international consortium of
investigative journalists angestoßene
Recherche die fragwürdige Geldflüsse von
Russland nach Deutschland sichtbar macht
Anlass der Recherchen sind geliegte
vertrauliche Unterlagen von zyprischen
Servicedienstleistern und gestern hab
die Überweisung von insgesamt 600.000 €
an den Journalisten und russlandexperten
Hubert Seipel schon die Schlagzeilen
bestimmt der Absender des Geldes ein
einflussreicher und kremmelner
russischer Oligarch namens Alexi
morderschow doch die Recherchen legen
auch offen wie russische Oligarchen wie
morderschow trotz geltender eu-sanktion
aktuell Geschäfte in Deutschland machen
hier seht ihr Herrn morderschof einmal
hinter mir wir wollen hier heute bei ZDF
heute live über bisher unveröffentlichte
Rechercheergebnisse zu zwei deutschen
Unternehmen sprechen und all das tun wir
gemeinsam mit Martha Oros und Hans
Koberstein sie sind Redakteurin und
Redakteur bei ZDF frontal und
anschließend sprechen wir über diese
Ergebnisse mit sanktionsexperte
Professor Victor Winkler und wie immer
hier bei ZTR fte live natürlich auch mit
euch da draußen vom Bildschirm wenn ihr
Fragen zu diesem Thema und zu diesen
spannenden Recherchen habt oder einfach
eure Meinung zum Thema mit uns teilen
wollt dann schreibt uns gerne hier in
den Youtube Chats oder per Mail an die
unten eingeblendete Adresse jetzt werfen
wir aber erstmal einen Blick auf das
sehr sehr umfangreiche rechercheprojekt
Cyprus
confidential Zypern ein Urlaubsparadies
im
Mittelmeer doch die Insel hat ein
schmutziges
Geheimnis hintergitzernden Fassaden
machen russische Milliardäre hee
Geschäfte vielleicht brauchen wir Russen
den Krieg um uns sozusagen zum Handeln
zu
bringen wer in Zypern recherchiert
erhält Einblick in eine
Schattenwelt schwarze Kassen für dubiose
fußballgeschäfte die schlimmste
Konsequenz wre der Ausschluss aus der
Premier geheime Absprachen um Millionen
Schw Kunst zu
versteenagurenet
auch um Vermögen zu
verschleier wir recherchieren weil sie
sanktionierte russische Oligarchen unter
ihren Kunden haben in der Hauptstadt
Zyperns werden geheime Verträge
geschlossen die nie ans Licht kommen
sollten haben Sie jemals Honorar
Russland bezogen aus Russland
dirw no ein heimliches Honorar für einen
deutschen
journalenin Fragen
beantworten ja und über ihre Arbeit und
bisher unveröffentlichte
Rechercheergebnisse spreche ich jetzt
mit Martha Oros und Hans Koberstein die
mir schon zugeschaltet sind schönen
guten Abend
hallo und auch beide selbst Teil von
Cyprus confidential sind und für ZDF
frontal mit recherchieren Matha mehr als
270 Journalistinnen und Journalisten
sind Teil dieses
rechercheprojekts erzähl mal wie seid
ihr bei der Recherche innerhalb mehrerer
Millionen Datensätze vorgegangen guckt
man da alles einzeln an
es waren mehr als
3,6 Millionen Dateien und
es hätte glaube ich Jahre gedauert wenn
wir das alles einzeln ausgewertet hätten
umso wichtiger war es dass wir vom
Anfang an Strategien haben und
es war auch wichtig zu wissen warum oder
wofür für Zypern überhaupt attraktiv ist
und es gibt drei Hauptgründe
dafür die niedrige Steuersätze die
Lachse geldwäscheekontrollen und
außerdem gibt's auf Zypern eine
Industrie von serviceagenturen
sogenannen serviceagenturen die
briefkassenfirmen gründen und diese
verwalten und mit diesem Wissen haben
wir dann auch
Listen erstellt Listen von Politikern
von sanktionierten Personen von Personen
des öffentlichen Lebens aber auch von
Unternehmen die wir dann automatisiert
in die Suchmaske eingegeben haben und so
haben wir die diesen Datensatz
durchsucht und das hat uns natürlich die
Arbeit erleichtert und so konnten wir
dann auch weiter
recherchieren ja ziemlich spannend Hans
wir haben es gerade schon in dem Trailer
gesehen diese Enthüllung um Journalist
und Autor Hubert Seipel die waren ja
gestern schon ziemlich viel in den
Schlagzeilen der renommierte Autor und
auch Putin Experte soll laut den
Recherchen 600.000 € aus Russland Land
bekommen haben erzähl mal wie seid ihr
auf diese Zahlen gestoßen also auf
Hubert Seipel zu kommen war
lustigerweise gar nicht mal so schwer
weil
es er ist einer derjenigen die ziemlich
die man sofort als Treffer kriegt wenn
man nach Journalisten sucht in dem
Datenleck allerdings ist das dann
Wikipediaeintrag von Hubert Seipel wo
man sich fragt warum will so eine
Serviceagentur aus Zypern Wikipedia
Eintrag von Hubert Seipel abspeichern
und es war dann das Verdienst von
unserem Kollegen Timo Schober von paper
tril Media dem ZDF Partner der da
weitergegaben hat und der unermütlich
weitergesucht hat und dann schließlich
diesen Sponsorenvertrag herausgefischt
hat aus dieser Datenmenge und in dem
stand eben drin dass Hubert Seipel
600.000 € bekommen sollte und die ihm
dann auch transferiert worden sind für
seine Arbeit an einem Buchprojekt das
schwierige was sich dann anschloss war
zu schauen woher kommt denn das Geld
also eine zyprische Briefkastenfirma hat
normalerweise selbst nicht Geld sondern
das kommt dann irgendwoh her und diese
geldspur zu verfolgen das war sehr sehr
aufwendig da musste man sich dann so von
einem Dokument zum nächsten hangeln sich
immer wieder neue Recherche Strategien
überlegen in dieser riesigen Datenmenge
um dann viele auch falsche Spuren zu
verfolgen also wir haben da teilweise
Stunden damit verbracht spugen
Detailfragen zu klären die dann im
Nichts geändet sind da mussten wir dann
wieder zurück auf Los und uns was neues
überlegen letztendlich haben wir das
dann herausgefunden wohin die Spur führt
nämlich über Briefkastenfirmen auf den
britischen
jungfernineln nach Russland zu einem
comppagnon von Alexei morderschov und
dann konnten wir auch die Geldflüsse
nachvollziehen und zwar die liefen dann
über Firmen die zu Alexei morderschow
gehören über diese Briefkastenfirma die
dann den Sponsorenvertrag mit Hubert
zeipel abgeschlossen hatte und die ihm
dann schließlich die 600.000 €
überwiesen
hat ja ziemlich spannend vor allem das
mit dem Wikipedia Eintrag Matha wir
haben direkt eine Frage aus der
Community an Dich die auch eure
Arbeitsweise als
investigativjournalistin betrifft hier
fragt jemand woher bzw von wem kamen die
leags weiß man
sowas die Quelle werden wir und dürfen
wir natürlich auch überhaupt nicht
verraten das ist ja ein
Grundprinzip von von unserer Arbeit
ähm was wir wissen dass
zumindest ein Teil von von diesem leaks
könnte vielleicht auch sogar aus einem
Hackerangriff stammen aber es ist
wichtig zu wissen dass die leaks für uns
sind natürlich nur der Startpunkt für
für die Recherche das heißt wir haben
die leaks wir haben die Daten die
schauen wir uns an aber das schließt
natürlich nicht aus oder bzw das
impliziert auch dass wir dann auch mit
Experten sprechen mit Quellen sprechen
und dann auch weiter recherchieren und
die Geschichten stützen sich im Prinzip
am Ende aus auf eine Kombination von den
Inhalten aus diesen leaks aber auch
natürlich von Vorort Recherche auf
Zypern oder wo auch immer uns diese
Geschichte hinführt mhm hier auf den
Bildern sehen wir dich quasi gerade bei
der Arbeit
von diesen Geldflüssen von morderschof
an Hubert Seipel von denen haben wir ja
gestern schon ziemlich viel gehört ihr
zwei habt uns aber auch heute hier für
ztf heute live zwei spannende neue Fälle
mitgebracht die bisher unveröffentlicht
sind Martha dabei geht es auch um ein
Unternehmen hier in Deutschland in
Dortmund was hat es damit auf
sich genau also wir haben entdeckt
dass der Oligarch Alexi morderschop über
den wir ja bisher wussten dass er der
dass er TUI Großaktionär ist wir haben
entdeckt in diesen Daten leaks dass er
auch ein Unternehmen ein Hightech
Unternehmen in Dortmund besaß bis ende
dezember
2022 das heißt der war Eigentümer eines
hightechunternehmens Namens inolume auch
nachdem er sanktioniert wurde wir wissen
dass die Sanktionen am 28 Februar 22 in
Kraft getreten sind
und er hat anscheinend seine
Unternehmensanteile oder dieses
Unternehmen an dem Geschäftsführer des
Unternehmens erst im Dezember 22
übertragen oder verkauft die konkreten
Umstände kennen wir nicht wir haben
mehrmals den Geschäftsführer gefragt und
wir wollten wissen wie denn so ein
Verkauf oder so eineer Übertragung
möglich ist denn die eine Partei also
der der der Eigentümer oder der heute
ehemalige Eigentümer ist ja sanktioniert
aber diese Fragen hat ließen sich bis
jetzt nicht aufklären es ist definitiv
interessant dass Alexi morderschow nicht
nur an
einem Unternehmen wie TUI also ein
Reisekonzern Interesse hatte sondern
auch an einem mittelständischen
Unternehmen aus Dortmund ein
hightechunternehmen was Laser Chips
produziert für KI Rechenzentren für für
für Medizin oder für die Industrie und
er auch bis quasi Ende vergangenen
Jahres da Eigentümer war mhm wenn man
jetzt hört high technology Laser Chips
KI dann sind es ja alles Wichtige
zukunftsweisende Technologien wisst ihr
schon was die Motivation des Oligarchen
hinter dieser Beteiligung war versucht
man da vielleicht auch wissen abzuziehen
nach
Russland Matha
äh wir haben natürlich Herrn morderschow
gefragt viele Fragen gestellt auch zu zu
seiner Beteiligung an an diesem
Unternehmen an in lume
er hat auf diese Fragen konkret nicht
geantwortet er hat betont dass er oder
seine Sprecherin hat Beton dass
dass er sich immer bei jedem Unternehmen
was er hatte oder was er hat und wo er
beteiligt war immer sich an Gesetze
gehalten hat was seine Motivation war
2008 in dieses Unternehmen einzusteigen
das wissen wir
nicht ja wir sehen die Recherchen zu
diesem Fall sind auf jeden Fall noch
nicht zu Ende Hans du hast uns auch ein
Rechercheergebnis mitgebracht was bisher
unveröffentlicht ist und was mit einem
weiteren deutschen Unternehmen zu tun
hat und zwar mit dem Unternehmen
lagerlöwe das ist ein Unternehmen für
self storage Stellplätze was hat es mit
diesem Fall auf
sich dieses Unternehmen wurde in
Deutschland aufgebaut seit 2009 2019
von der Muttergesellschaft in Zypern aus
floss das Geld an für mehrere Standorte
für dem Aufbau mehrere Standorte von
diesen self storage sites in deutschen
Städten in Leipzig entsteht gerade ein
ganz neuer Bau von lagerlöwe und die
Recherchen haben gezeigt dass die
Eigentümer
äh zwei russische Oligarchen sind die
seit November vergangenen Jahres auf der
britischen Sanktionsliste stehen auf der
Sanktionsliste
Großbritanniens und diese das Besondere
daran ist dass die Geschäftsführer die
deutschen Geschäfts der deutsche
Geschäftsführer dieser Gesellschaft hat
gegenüber den deutschen Behörden
angegeben dass der Eigentümer er selbst
ist und die weiteren Geschäftsführer
dieser Gesellschaft und eben nicht die
rischen Oligarchen und da müssen wundern
wir uns natürlich und fragen uns
ist das denn richtig ist das eine
richtige Angabe gegenüber den deutschen
Behörden oder wurde da etwas nicht
richtig gemacht und wir haben natürlich
versucht den deutschen Geschäftsführer
zu befragen der hat gesagt er darf
überhaupt nichts sagen dazu und hat uns
verwiesen auf eine pragentur aus London
die uns dann auch tatsächlich angerufen
hat und der wir dann auch unsere Fragen
geschickt haben genauso wie dem
Geschäftsführer nur haben beide uns
bislang nicht geantwortet also da steht
noch einiges an Recherche aus um dem auf
den Grund zu gehen ob hier
möglicherweise falsche Angaben gegenüber
deutschen Behörden gemacht worden sind
um das Investment in einer
wahrscheinlich zweistelligen
Millionenhöhe in ein deutsches
Unternehmen von russischen Oligarchen
die von Großbritannien mittlerweile
sanktioniert sind und eventuell
demnächst von der EU vielleicht
sanktioniert werden
könnten ja ob dieses Unternehmen also
sozusagen immer noch die russischen
Oligarchen gehört mhm wir müssen uns das
denn vorstellen wie seid ihr bei dieser
Art von Recherchen
vorgegangen also das war sehr
anstrengend weil dieses
Mutterunternehmen von lagerlöwe das
sitzt auf Zypern das hat wiederum ein
Mutterunternehmen das sitzt auf Zypern
das hat wiederum ein Mutterunternehmen
das sitzt auf dem Britischen
Jungferninseln das hat ein
Mutterunternehmen das sitzt auf den
Britischen Jungferninseln das hat
wiederum ein Mutterunternehmen das sitzt
auf dem den britischen jungfaninseln und
das wiederum also ich könnte das jetzt
endlos weiter erzählen die
Unternehmensstruktur ist unglaublich
verschachtelt und da muss man dann genau
gucken welche Informationen gibt es äh
die belegen dass die Eigentümerstruktur
zu welchem Zeitpunkt wie gewesen ist wie
sind da die Geldflüsse gewesen welche
Kredite wurden nach Deutschland
ausgereicht wer hat wem welche Anweisung
gegeben äh dem dass den deutschen
Behörden gegenüber falsche Angaben
gemacht werden sollten möglicherweise
was die Eigentümer angeht ähm also da
haben wir einiges zusammengetragen an
Dokumenten die doch sehr viele Fragen
aufwerfen und da sind wir jetzt immer
noch in der Recherche und bei der
Klärung mhm das sind jetzt also zwei
deutsche Unternehmen in die zu einem
Zeitpunkt russische Oligarchen
involviert waren sogar auch mit recht
hohen Anteilen und da fragt man sich
jetzt natürlich
ist das jetzt erstmal nur die Spitze des
Eisberges und kommt da noch viel mehr
raus
mattha das ist ist schwer zu sagen es
ist glaube ich ähm wichtig zu wissen
dass wir nur einen Ausschnitt sehen
dadurch dass wir leags von
von von insgesamt sieben Service
sogenannten serviceagenturen und
Unternehmen
haben und zypern hat ja eine wirklich
große Industrie für für
briefkassenfirmen für Firmen die
Vermögen verwalten äh für Vermögen der
Russen oder vor für für andere nicht
euausländer ähm von daher ist es
wirklich schwer zu ähäh zu sehen was auf
jeden Fall interessant ist und das
können wir nach glaube ich drei 3 vi
Monate Recherche sagen ist dass wir
relativ wenige deutsche Unternehmen in
diesem League gefunden haben wir haben
zwar dem Rif
GmbH oft eingegeben und und und und und
auch viel durchsucht aber die meisten
solche GmbHs waren in Österreich
registriert also keine deutsche
Unternehmen es sieht also danach aus
dass Zypern ähm wahrscheinlich doch
nicht so attraktiv ist für für für
deutsche Unternehmen auch wenn die
Steuern niedriger sind und auch wenn
wenn es vielleicht auch sonniger ist
dort und die eine oder andere
Firmenstruktur eigenstruktur
Eigentümerstruktur lässt sich viel
besser verschleiern als
hier ja ich glaube
wir sind gespannt wie es mit diesen
Recherchen weitergeht die ja noch nicht
am Ende sind das haben wir gerade gehört
ich habe gerade mal den Chat geschaut
was unsere Community zu diesen
Ergebnissen sagt und hier schreibt
jemand auf Youtube solchen Journalisten
gehört ein großes Dankeschön für ihre
tolle Arbeit weiter so Martha und Hans
vielen Dank dass ihr bei uns wart bei
ZDF heute live und einen schönen Abend
noch danke tschüss
tschüss ja die Vorgänge die die beiden
gerade beschrieben haben die dürfte es
eigentlich aktuell gar nicht geben denn
kurz nach dem russischen Angriff auf die
Ukraine im letzten Februar belegte die
EU Russland mit Sanktionen mittlerweile
sogar mit mit dem Elen Sanktionspaket
das sind zum einen so
warenverkehrsbeschränkung aber das sind
aber auch Sanktionen gegen
Einzelpersonen oder Unternehmen das ist
das was wir gerade gehört haben wenn
russische Oligarchen wie hier im
Hintergrund auf sogenannten
Sanktionslisten stehen und wie
Oligarchen wie morderschof diese
Sanktion umgehen können und was es zur
Bekämpfung dieses Zustands braucht
darüber spreche ich jetzt mit einem
sanktionsexperten nämlich mit Professor
Viktor Winkler der uns jetzt
zugeschaltet ist schönen guten Abend
Herr Winkler guten Abend
Abend Herr Winkler wie überrascht sind
sie denn als Experte von solchen
Enthüllungen dass russische Oligarchen
diese EU Sanktion umgehen können also
ich bin nicht nur überrascht ich bin
offen gesagt fassungslos denn die Regel
ist das sicherlich nicht alle
Marktteilnehmer wissen inzwischen wie
ernst diese Sanktionen sind alle wissen
alle Vermögenswerte eines sanktionierten
sind einzufrieren was wir hier gehört
haben ist wirklich ein schockierendes
Ausmaß an höchstwahrscheinlich
Verletzungen der Sanktion und damit auch
Straftat ja hier fragt auch gerade
jemand aus der Community was machen
eigentlich die hochbezahlten
Staatssekretäre und topbeamten das ist
auch die Person die gerade so einen Lob
an die Journalisten ausgesprochen hat
was sind denn aus ihrer Sicht die
rechtlichen Folgen die sowas haben
müsste also was viele häufig vergessen
ist dass Sanktionen eben nicht nur
politische Bedeutung haben sondern jeder
sanktionsversto
ist eine Straftat eine Straftat nach
deutschem Recht mit allem was dazu
gehört mögliche Geldstrafen sogar
mögliche Haftstrafen wir haben jetzt
gesehen in Holland wir haben gesehen in
Frankreich gab es Haftstrafen
sanktionsvergehen in Deutschland ist ein
Unternehmer in Haft zwar nur
Untersuchungshaft aber also man sieht es
handelt sich um sehr sehr ernste
vergehen die für die Personen enorme
Konsequenzen haben können aber übrigens
auch für die Unterneh nehmen selber auch
dort gibt es Ordnungswidrigkeiten in
Millionenhöhe die im Raum stehen Ernst
zu vergehen mit ernsten strafrechtlichen
Folgen Hal mhm ähm lassen Sie uns noch
mal auf das Beispiel gucken was wir am
Anfang beschrieben haben nämlich diese
Geldflüsse von Russland an den
Journalisten und Putin Experten Hubert
Seipel der hat diese Geldflüsse ja
mittlerweile auch eingeräumt wie ist
denn da die Lage was für rechtliche
folgen kann das haben also mich hat ein
bisschen gewundert wie viel gesprochen
wurde über diesen Fall und wie selten
erwähnt worden ist dass er
höchstwahrscheinlich eine Straftat
begangen hat also es ist eine
unausgesprochene Lage dieses Vertrages
dass ich natürlich keine 600.000 € von
Russland bekomme wenn ich so einen
Verlagsvertrag unterzeichnen heißt wenn
ich nicht aktiv aufkläre darüber mein
Verleger du pass auf ich bekomme hier
600 000 € dann ist das eine Täuschung
eine Täuschung die zu einem zu einer
Vermögensverfügung gehört hat geführt
hat also hier im konkreten Fall dass er
überhaupt ein Buch verlegen durfte ein
klassischer betrug insofern glaube ich
dass die Staatsanwaltschaft hier
zumindest ein Ermittlungsverfahren
einleiten sollte und dann werden wir
sehen ob es zu der Straftat dann auch
tatsächlich gekommen ist aber mich stört
ein bisschen dass immer gesagt wird ja
politisch ist das
aber es ist auch eine Straftat hier im
Raum und das sollte wirklich von der
Staatsanwaltschaft untersucht
werden ja und wichtig dazu ist auch noch
zu sagen dass der NDR als ehemalige
Arbeitgeber von Seipel aktuell
rechtliche Schritte prüft hier fragt
jemand auf
Youtube das ist ja alles bekannt wann
kommt es denn zur Anklage auch der
anderen Machenschaften die da bekannt
sind was müss denn jetzt passieren dass
es ganz konkret zu einer Anklage kommen
könnte
sie meinen im Fall Seipel
äh oder im Fall der russischen
Oligarchen also die Fälle die wir jetzt
gehört haben um das mal rechtlich ein
bisschen einzuordnen da handelt es sich
um höchstwahrscheinlich klare Verstöße
gegen das sogenannte
einfrierungsgebot denn man muss immer
bedenken die Sanktionen verlangen nicht
dass man irgendwas verkauft so wie wir
das offenbar bei diesem Geschäftsführer
haben die Sanktionen sind sehr klar kein
Verkauf kein zerstören kein Eigentum
wegnehmen einfrieren was heißt
einfrieren niemand darf dran niemand
insbesondere auch nicht der der
Berechtigte darf an dieses Objekt gehen
und offenbar wurde in diesen Fällen
alles andere als eingeforen es wurde
versucht umzuschichten zu verschleiern
alles das sind Straftaten also was dazu
gehört ist eine Staatsanwaltschaft die
sich hier zuständig fühlt
sei es in Zypern sei es in Deutschland
je nach Fall und die hier anfängt zu
ermitteln noch mal es handelt sich um
schwerwiegende Straftaten die im Raum
stehen solange die Staatsanwaltschaften
hier nicht ermitteln glaube ich wird es
nicht wirklich zu einer Aufdeckung und
zu einer weiteren Durchsetzung der
Sanktionen kommen denn diese Personen
sind so vermögenend sie fürchten keine
Geldstrafen aber strafrechtliche
Ermittlungen fürchten sie schon mhm und
gerade kommt es ja äh nicht nur ähm zu
zu wenig strafrechtlichen Ermittlungen
sondern allein schon diese Fälle zu
benennen das passiert ja gerade wie wir
gehört haben vor allem durch
investigative journalistinn und
Journalisten was braucht es denn aus
ihrer Sicht damit die Sanktionen die wir
jetzt schon seit über eineinhalb Jahren
noch länger gegen Russland verhängt
haben dass die auch wirklich wirken gibt
es quasi sowas wie in diesem Fall
wirksamere Sanktion also ich freue mich
sehr über die Frage weil die Frage wird
viel zu selten gestellt in den Medien um
es kurz zu machen die Antwort ist wir
brauchen zwei Dinge wir brauchen zum
einen eine spezialisierte Poli
sie müssen sich ja vorstellen zur Zeit
ist die Durchsetzung dieser Sanktionen
in der Hand der Länderpolizei das ist
der Wachtmeister von der Ecke das ist
die straßenpolizistin von der Ecke das
sind gute Leute und intelligent aber sie
sind völlig fachlich natürlich
überfordert von der Komplexität dieser
dieser Straftaten also wir brauchen eine
spezialisierte Polizei die gibt es
übrigens in Italien die heißt dann mit
dem schönen Namen Gua die finanzaer und
das zweite was wir brauchen Trans enz
bei den Unternehmen sie müssen sich
vorstellen ihre Beispiele zeigen das ja
wunderbar in den British Virgin Islands
in diesen ganzen oversea territories
haben wir immer noch nicht eine
vollständige Transparenz wem gehört
welches Unternehmen man hat einen großen
Sprung gemacht 2022 übrigens wegen der
russlandsanktion den Sprung gemacht aber
die ersten Studien liegen schon vor die
uns zeigen es funktioniert nicht so
richtig und wenn sie in d bauen in einem
Fluss den sie nur halb bauen dann bringt
das gar nichts dann ist das so als wäre
gar kein DM da weil der Fluss eben das
Wasser weiterfließt und das ist leider
die Situation nein wir brauchen
Transparenz wir brauchen Transparenz bei
den oversea territories also
Bermuda British Virgin Islands aber auch
ltenstein auch Luxemburg wir müssen
endlich wissen können wem gehört welches
Unternehmen wer sind die Anteilseigner
solange wir nicht die Transparenz hier
haben wer wird ein Großteil unserer
Sanktionen leider ins Leere
laufen wir haben gerade schon von ihnen
und auch von den Kolleginnen gehört
gerade in in in Luxemburg in in
Lichtenstein in Zypern oder auf Zypern
gibt es Verhältnisse die sowas
erleichtern und hier sagt jemand auf
YouTube in Deutschland herrschen für
westliche Verhältnisse paradiesische
Zustände für Geldwäsche und
Steueroptimierung wen wundert es da
würden sie da
mitgehen nein nein in dieser Schafe ist
es zu viel was sicherlich richtig ist
ist dass wir noch ein Weg haben auch in
Deutschland wir leben auch nicht hier im
im Paradies sondern wir haben auch ein
hartes geldwäscheproblem auch ein
sanktionsumgehrungsproblem aber die
Transparenzpflichten in Deutschland wenn
man die jetzt vergleicht mit Zypern das
durchaus aufgeholt hat aber vor allem
vergleicht das ist mir wichtig mit
diesen oversea territories die die
Engländer haben dann ist das schon ein
massiver Unterschied wir sehen immer
wieder dass die Oligarchen Deutschland
vielleicht für Real Estate also
Immobilien benutzen aber für diese
Verschachtelung und in all diesen Fällen
über die wir heute sprechen spielen ja
Verschachtelung und Shell companies eine
Rolle in diesen Shell companies ist
nicht Deutschland der große Akteur
insofern würde ich sagen nicht so sehr
Deutschland ist gefordert sondern
sondern die Regulierung dieser anderen
Steueroasen oversea territories aber das
spielt Deutschland eine große Rolle herr
Scholz die Regierung kann hier und
sollte hier Einfluss ausüben Deutschland
hat eine große Macht durchaus im
politischen Konzert und ob ob diese
Regierung bisher ihre gesamte ihren
gesamten Einfluss hat gelten machen in
diese Richtung habe ich auch noch nicht
mitbekommen also da sehe ich die großen
Probleme und da sehe ich die Bringschuld
insbesondere der
ampelregierung lassen sie uns zum
Schluss noch mal auf die Verfolgung
dieser Machenschaften kommen sie haben
eben davon gesprochen in Deutschland
gibt es auch überforderte Beamte die für
solche Vorgänge gar nicht ausgebildet
sein in der Tiefe jetzt fragt hier
jemand auf Youtube konnten oder wollten
die Behörden das vielleicht auch nicht
sehen muss da ein bisschen doch die
Politik dann in diesem Punkt in Schutz
nehmen man darf ja nicht vergessen das
sanktionst sehr neu Sanktionen gibt es
überhaupt erst noch gar nicht so lange
und dieses größte komplexeste
Sanktionspaket in der Geschichte das wir
jetzt bei Russland haben gibt es auch
nur in Anführungszeichen seit anderthalb
Jahren also diese völlig neue Qualität
von Sanktionen ich sag das als jemand
der spezialisiert ist auf dieses Thema
diese Spezialisierung diese Komplexität
gibt es noch nicht so lange wir erleben
den Beginn eines Kulturwandels ich hoffe
dieser Kulturwandel geht weiter ähm aber
die Politik und die Verwaltung hängt
dahinterher ein böser Wille erkenne ich
dahinen bösen Willen erkenne ich
dahinter nicht es wird dauern aber man
muss auch fairerweise sagen es ist nicht
nur die Polizei gefragt
sanktionsverletzungen zu arnten ist
Aufgabe von uns allen
sie und die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
haben da ja sehr viel geleistet aber wir
alle müssen auch mithelfen dabei wir
alle müssen die Sanktionen durchsetzen
wir alle können etwas tun die
Unternehmen müssen und können sehr sehr
viel tun also es geht nicht nur um den
Staat alle müssen gemeinsam diesen
Kulturwandel mitmachen wir müssen alle
verstehen was diese Sanktionen sind
warum sie so wichtig sind und wie
gefährlich es ist wenn man gegen
Sanktionen
verstößt und zum Schluss haben wir noch
eine quasi technische Frage zum
sanktionsprinzip es fragt jemand auf
Youtube darf der Staat die Bankkonten
von russischen Oligarchen in Deutschland
zwangsenteignen nein
endlich kann mal ein Jurist eine klare
Antwort geben nein das ist nicht erlaubt
das geben die Gesetze nicht her man darf
ja nicht nicht vergessen der
sanktionierte Oligarch ist kein
Verbrecher sanktioniert zu werden selbst
ist noch keine Straftat die
Sanktionierung führt zu einer Reihe von
Pflichten wenn man die verletzt
insbesondere Meldepflichten über das
Vermögen dann begeht man eine Straftat
solange man dies nicht tut ist man nur
wenn man sanktioniert ist kein
Straftäter und deswegen können wir nicht
enteignen wir können nicht
beschlagnahmen das ist auch so ein alter
Mythos wir beschlagnahmen jetzt die Jagt
nein jagt darf nicht beschlagnahmt
werden sie muss eingefroren werden und
sie muss nicht beschlagnahmt werden also
der sanktionierte rechtslagestand heute
bleibt
Eigentümer und wenn die Sanktionen
wieder geliftet also wenn die wieder
aufgehoben werden dann theoretisch
werden die Abramovic dieser Welt alle
ihre jaachten wiederbekommen das kann
man ändern man könnte ein neues Gesetz
machen die EU könnte das ändern es gibt
dazu auch Pläne ich als Jurist sage aber
höchstwahrscheinlich wäre das drig aber
stand heute bleibt der sanktionierte
Eigentümer all dieser schönen Bilder und
Jachten und wenn die Sanktionen
irgendwann aufgeroben werden darf sie
auch wieder
benutz
einfrieren also statt enteignen Herr
winler vielen Dank dass Sie meine Fragen
und die Fragen der Community beantwortet
haben schönen Abend noch sehr gerne
schönen
Abend ja und wie es mit den
Machenschaften russischer Oligarchen in
Deutschland weitergeht und was neu
Recherchen als Ergebnis haben hierbei ZF
heute live werdet ihr es erfahren vielen
Dank für eure Fragen und Kommentare und
bis zum nächsten
Mal